la plupart d'entre nous n’étaient pas
née était trop jeune ou n'avait pas la
télévision mais tout le monde a vu un
jour ces images de l'événement
inoubliables qui a été le couronnement
de la reine Elizabeth II le 2 juin 1953
un événement mondial le premier de l'ère
moderne diffusé en direct par la BBC
plupart des gens n'ont pas la télévision
alors il la regarde où ils peuvent dans
les ambassades des cinémas des journaux
avec des téléviseurs placés à
l'extérieur en noir et blanc évidemment
la télévision
existait depuis 9 mois elle était
nouvelle j'en avais pas chez moi je
regardais ça dans les vitrines des
magasins à l'époque comme beaucoup de
gens les yeux de la planète sont braqués
sur Londres tout le monde aime les
contes de fées les commentateurs
rivalisent de virtuosité
3 millions de spectateurs sont en effet
debout sur le passage du cortège la
plupart ont passé la nuit à leur place
mais la vue du carrosse Dory le visage
clair de cette reine de 27 ans qui
symbolise l'avenir britannique sont une
magnifique récompense
car il fait froid il a plu à Londres
[Musique]
en février 1952 lorsque le roi George VI
décède elisabeth est à l'étranger Rennes
improbable elle doit la couronne à
l’abdication de son oncle Édouard VII
frère du roi elle ne sera couronnée que
16 mois plus tard le temps de se
demander faut-il ou non faire rentrer
les caméras de télévision dans l'abbaye
de ouateminster le prince Philippe lui à
cette époque était pour déjà une
certaine modernisation de la monarchie
et souhaitait que l'on diffuse le
couronnement alors il y a eu un débat il
y avait aussi une objection de fond chez
Churchill et chez les vieux théoriciens
de la monarchie en Angleterre qui était
à la suivante on ne laisse pas entrer la
lumière du jour dans la magie
solennellement sur la Bible devant
l'église à respecter toutes les
promesses qu'elle avait faites
verbalement
de Londres et c'était Gérard Arthur un
commentateur très officiel de la radio
très institutionnelle très très belle
diction très cultivée alors qui
décrivait à l'intérieur de l'abbaye de
Westminster
sur les écrans de télévision
spectateurs dans d'autres images pour
l'instant qu'une tenture un tableau la
reine est couronnée
le prince Philippe son premier sujet lui
porte allégeance Elisabeth la reine mère
veille sur le petit Charles prince de
Galles à l'extérieur de l'abbaye c'était
des grands correspondeurs de
Radio-Canada
Judy jasmin René Lévesque lui-même qui
ont suivi tous les deux le couronnement
d'Elisabeth II il pleuvait il pleuvait
beaucoup même
au moment où le carrosse royal de grand
carrosse d'apparat parle devant nous
j'ai eu tout juste le temps des cartions
des dieux comme tout le monde
lapercevoir une base silhouette et de
voir cette René l'évêque après avoir
décrit tout ça il dit après avoir
regardé ce couronnement moi j'ai compris
pourquoi les gens disaient
l'anglais de Queen il termine son
sa série de reportage comme ça
[Musique]
la magie elle est à la télévision la
magie du direct dans quatre autres pays
d'Europe au Canada avant l'air des
satellites presque c'est un pont aérien
qui va transporter les bobines qui s'est
appelé en langage en cas de militaire
pour les Express
on a enregistré le couronnement on
mettait ça sur une bobine la bobine
était acheminée et c'était la BBC qui
faisait ça qui envoyait ça
et là on transportait la bobine sur un
bon Barbier Canberra
Londres goosebay en 5h30 puis goosebay
Saint-Hubert par avion militaire
canadien un CF s'en fièrement piloté par
George
nikersenber la bobine était transportée
sur les 10 fils de Radio-Canada rue
Dorchester à l'époque près de Bishop et
là la bobine était diffusée à
Radio-Canada
le couronnement est diffusé à la
télévision en anglais avec le
commentaire de la BBC il était en direct
à la radio les descriptions de Gérard
Arthur René l'évêque et Judy jasmin ont
été collés plus tard sur les images les
images couleurs proviennent d'un film
tourné à l'occasion et monté ensuite la
télévision a redonné vie à une monarchie
qu'on disait anachronique dans un pays
affaibli épuisé par la deuxième guerre
mondiale 70 ans plus tard à quelques
jours près l'exploit sera difficile à
reproduire Jean-Michel Leprince a du
Canada Montréal